a great beginning is important but it
isn't everything and that definitely
applies to the movies plenty of films
get off the starting block just fine but
sometimes those interesting opening acts
are just a Frehley to a series of
stumbles that end in utter collapse here
is our list of movies with great
beginnings that fell apart after minute
Jonah Hex
who doesn't love a sci-fi Western it's a
genre that keeps on giving where the
small screen is concerned consider the
lasting popularity of TV shows like
Firefly and West world's the full-on
disaster Wild Wild West made it seem
like a good sci-fi Western might never
make it onto silver screen but Jonah Hex
had a shot at turning things around it's
comic book origin provided rich source
material about a troubled antihero who
was accused of being a turncoat and a
traitor to his Confederate Army unit
there's enough content right there for a
solid movie all on its own however the
movies numerous last-minute changes
dogged the film's production and turned
the final product into an unintentional
disaster movie despite a few solid intro
scene search juices gone good didn't
renew The Last Airbender M night
Shyamalan live-action take on The Last
Airbender should have been good the
cartoon series certainly was but the
film version was plagued by accusations
of cast whitewashing and the actors who
wound up in the film were misused anyway
and largely made into movie mockeries
pretty much the best thing about the
movie is its opening credits which show
people using Tai Chi to manipulate the
element and that dimly lit 15-second
demonstration is as good as this movie
ever gets what a shame Star Wars Episode
one The Phantom Menace let's face it
Star Wars Episode one The Phantom Menace
make Battlefield Earth look like a new
hope running on a crooked projector much
has been made of the fact that Jar Jar
Binks and a number of new aliens come
across as thinly disguised ethnic
stereotypes but that is that definitely
is this thing barely hangs together as
an actual movie all things considered
the movie does open on a high note the
screen is black and the comforting
mantra a long time ago in a galaxy far
far
appears on screen accompanied by silence
than the classic epic fanfare Star Wars
was back after 16 years what could be a
better beginning to a movie than that
the first sentence of that old familiar
Star Wars crawl is pretty enticing to
turmoil has engulfed the Galactic
Republic turmoil you say what sort of
turmoil mr. Lucas fans were all excited
to learn the specifics but then swap the
whole thing basically turned into an
intergalactic vision of the Boston Tea
Party with a crazy costume game it is
clear to me now that the Republic no
longer functions no kidding good thing
the force awakens breathe new life into
the series by getting back to basics
because this movie and the two prequels
that followed were a hot mess
Transformers Revenge of the Fallen while
the Wahlberg Ian age of extinction gets
a lot of hate and dark of the moon isn't
exactly a work of art it's not much of a
stretch to pick revenge of the Fallen as
the ugliest of the subpar transformers
sequels it starts out in the usual
course with a follow-up to its robot
action predecessor by going back in time
to the start of those robotic renegades
but then things start to fall into some
shady territory with a racist Robo
thread running through the entirety of
this itchy CGI sweater of cinematics in
that it pulls causes Bay's movie to
completely collapse from the
unflattering characteristics of a
stereotypically primitive tribesman to
the minstrelsy of the twins mudflap and
skids what are we going to do with this
shrimp taco what the Kapiti - show me
the truck it in a wagon oh no not me -
the pervasive racially tinged one-liners
revenge of the Fallen retrofits a
beloved sci-fi franchise with deplorable
racist rope and then only gets worse
from there
Batman vs Superman dawn of Justice
director Zack Snyder has some explaining
to do the widely derided Batman vs
Superman dawn of Justice wasn't his
first superhero movie so there's no
excuse for why he got this one so wrong
putting Batman and Superman together for
the very first time in a live action
movie was a short thing by any measure
then the fact that Wonder Woman was also
added to the mix made half the
blockbuster battle won even
without a script and that's kind of how
dawn of Justice met its downfall really
instead of a sensible narrative it's
just a collection of stuff that happens
much of which doesn't make a lick of
sense if you spend more than a couple
seconds thinking about it even the
Rock'em Sock'em fun inherit in the title
gets steamrolled by a grim loud and
utterly preposterous final showdown
between our two main heroes that's
ultimately settled because those of
their moms are named Martha Wu and
things started off pretty well sure
there was the terrible poetry corner
courtesy of Ben Affleck there was a time
above the time before there were perfect
thing but once we get to Bruce Wayne
zipping around metropolis as it's being
turned into a smoking crater thanks to
Superman and Zod it's tough not to get
excited about the high-stakes drama to
come and then well she gave me fake that
there's goodness world she was my world
so yeah in terms of concept brand legacy
and overall anticipation Batman vs
Superman dawn of Justice got off to an
excellent start and then the rest of the
movie showed up thanks for watching
click the looper icon to subscribe to
our YouTube channel let's check out all
this cool stuff we know you love to
[Music]
[Applause]